We are transformed, in a way,
through this experience.
All of us very much believe
that this feels like the
most important movie we've ever made.
That is what every crew member
focused on every day, and none more so
than Ryan Coogler
at the helm of it all.
Ryan has such a big heart
and is such a great storyteller.
The actors that he's brought together
were filled with emotion and passion.
WINSTON DUKE
Reuniting with Ryan Coogler
was incredible.
LETITIA WRIGHT
His heart is really pure
and we should protect
him at all cost.
[Laughing]
Ryan is an artist.
He has the heart to listen to you.
To look in your
eyes and go deep,
not just in the story,
but in your soul.
NATE MOORE
When you get down to what makes
this movie human,
that is where Ryan really excels.
I think even in a world as fantastical
and as magical and as exciting
as the Marvel Cinematic Universe...
He just has an
understanding of people.
RAMONDA
Now is our time.
RIRI WILLIAMS
Let's go!
There's an embracing of culture
and Ryan is going
a step further.
We're remembering,
we're restoring,
we're celebrating.
Above all, it is a relationship movie.
We'll have some incredible set pieces...
But at the end of the day,
I think what people are going to
really remember
is the conversations.
How do you move forward after
losing someone that meant so much to you?
You have to continue their legacy.